[Music]
a cartoon doesn't have to be funny in
order to be good
and i think that my work is is a
reflection of my sense of humor
but primarily i would consider myself
an artist who draws
his opinions about what is going on in
the news
in a way it's really no different than
what an editorial page
columnist would do but instead of using
a typewriter i'm using paper pen
and a drawing board
[Music]
you know a cartoon deals makes its point
through exaggeration
and exaggeration is certainly a large
part of caricature so when you're
drawing somebody
you're looking to accentuate or
exaggerate
certain features about that person to
make them very recognizable
you know hopefully getting to the point
after you
you've been drawing somebody for a while
where you don't need to use a label to
identify
that caricature so
in a way uh an artist can get away
with more than say a person who's
writing an opinion
but that's just the nature of caricature
and of satire
[Music]
bill clinton had a very has a very large
sense of humor
and he was one of the few presidents
that would actually
request uh original cartoons and he
enjoyed them and uh you know it was all
it was always a great charge to uh hear
from him
and have him uh request a cartoon it
took a while to learn
how to draw him uh which
you know my characters of him ended up
really concentrating on his chin
and exaggerating that chin in in order
to make him recognizable
and using his glasses a lot as a way to
make him recognizable
um so he was a fun and one of the
most fun cart presidents to caricature
i would say the same thing minus the
glasses
obviously there were a lot more cartoons
drawn about him because he was president
for two terms
but he was also a fun car uh fun
president to caricature
ronald reagan was probably one of the
best uh
presidents to caricature because he had
that
uh that pompadour in his hair he had a
lot of lines in his neck
and there you know it almost got to the
point where if you drew the hair
correctly you didn't really have to draw
too much else you could just make ronald
reagan
very recognizable a very difficult
president to caricature
there weren't a lot of things to
exaggerate
other than his ears and
he was probably one of the presidents
that was more
difficult to draw cartoons about
uh because my frankly a lot of my
politics align with his
so those eight years was a little more
difficult
to be as critical of him as some of the
other presidents that i've drawn
well the hair uh you know what can i say
uh
it's all about the hair and getting that
hair just right
and i think it took me at least three
years into his administration
to finally get to the point where i got
his hair to the point where
i actually liked the way it was drawn
and of course he was a treasure trove
for all
cartoonists because there was so much
controversy and so much constant news
about everything going on with him and
his administration
so he was a gold mine for cartoonists
[Music]
13 000 cartoons which is over a period
of uh over 35 years
uh these are all the cartoons that i've
drawn for the las vegas sun in my career
and these cartoons have been um you know
warehoused at the sun
and for the most part collecting dust
and we decided
that we needed to find um
a better way to preserve the cartoons
and to keep them
for any kind of future
research that students or classrooms
or individuals might be interested in
and unlv uh at their special collections
at the library special collections
department was very interested in taking
this
on and preserving the cartoons so we
were happy to
donate the work to them and they're
going to be able to
preserve it in a way that's accessible
to anybody that might want to
use it or read it or see it
it is often a lighthearted way
to make a point about what's going on in
the news there's a lot of
serious news going on and sometimes if
readers
can have a smile or a chuckle or
you know find some humor in something
that's going on in the news
i think that i think that makes them
feel good and makes them relate to the
cartoon